one of the most fascinating aspects of
your book
was identifying different moral values
that transcend
nationality or society that there are
things that just human beings
are wired for and you mentioned one of
them which is reciprocity which is if
someone uh does something nice for you
then we're wired to be nice
to them and you can see that uh you know
you and i are parents you can see that
with infants where if like you smile
they're likely to smile back
it's kind of like like most of the uh
the interaction you have
uh and so you're identifying these six
universal
moral values i thought was so important
uh and those moral values you identified
were
uh caring fairness
sanctity loyalty authority
and then you also identified liberty and
if you look at these values liberals and
progressives tend to operate more on the
caring and fairness dimensions and
conservatives tend to
operate more along the lines of
uh sanctity loyalty and authority right
social liberty being interpreted yeah
social conservatives that's right yeah
uh
with liberty being interpreted and
valued slightly differently
uh by each side that's right so
you know i i love metaphors and the
human mind is a pattern matcher we think
in metaphors
so if you have a good metaphor makes it
easy to understand something so the
metaphor that i think is best here is
you know our our we all have the same
tongues more or less and
our tongue you know if you're a human
being your tongue has five taste
receptors for
sweet sour salt bitter and umami which
is kind of a meat flavor
because we evolved our ancestors ate
meat and fruit and so those guide us to
the right things
so we all have the same taste receptors
but
depending on what culture you grow up in
you have a different cuisine and maybe
you know
it i like i thought america had a lot of
a lot of sweetness but then i went to
chile in chile they consume more sugar
than anyone on earth
and like everything everything is so
sickly sweet in
chile but that's what they're used to
and other cuisines are spicier and have
you know
um anyway the point is we have an
evolved nature that guides us to things
that were good for our ancestors and we
have
cultural nature that grew up
historically based on local
circumstances and it's the same thing
with morality
so care is the easiest one to understand
because we're mammals
and what it means to be a mammal is that
you nurture
your young for a long time you have huge
parental investment
and for most mammals it's only the
female that makes the investment but in
humans and a
few other species males fall in love
with their kids and make make the
investment too
so we all have tremendous sensitivity to
suffering and we see
you know like that famous photo of a two
a two-year-old washed up on the beach in
in southern europe
that was you know so powerful for during
the uh immigration
uh issue in europe um we all are
wired to respond now conservatives love
their children and
and and have sympathy for suffering but
conservative morality is not based
primarily on that
whereas left-wing moralities especially
modern western left-wing
is based much more on compassion care um
there how you think society should be
ordered is based on that foundation
conservatives have that foundation but
their morality is not heavily based on
it
fairness second one uh as you said
reciprocity our
our ancestors are revolved to trade we
we trade
not just things we trade insults we
trade um
uh favors so reciprocity is very deep in
us and
if you do something for someone and they
don't reciprocate we we
hold on to that we resent that we have a
strong sense of people who take more
than they give
uh but in some cultures uh you
you have such a rigid such attention to
direct fairness
that if that if somebody you know
insults somebody in your family
you now have to insult someone in theirs
or it quickly escalates to a feud and
you
you know violence and in other
subcultures it's turn the other cheek
or just brush it off um so we all have
the same moral foundations but
different cultures construct them
differently and as you said the social
conservatives in the united states
um uh they they do
you know they rely on care to some
extent fairness for them
is proportionality if you do the crime
you do the time
whereas fairness on the left is more
about equality and nowadays especially
quality of outcome and if you have
disparities if you have one group is
doing better than another that
looks on the surface to be unfair
because it's unequal
so we all talk about fairness but we
mean something different
and then liberty uh is kind of similar
on the left and the right except that on
the left
people see corporations and rich people
as the oppressors as the ones that need
to be overthrown
historically going all the way back to
marx whereas on the right
uh the american right it's government
there's a real
government is is the bully and you know
we have to arm ourselves and second
amendment and all that
so those three foundations are are used
by both sides but they mean something
different
and then loyalty authority and sanctity
those three are heavily used by social
conservatives and they are largely
rejected
by by the modern left because those seem
those are the
the psychological foundations of
tribalism of group loyalty
uh if you know fascist country fascist
morality is very heavily based on
group loyalty authority to the the
strong man
and a sense of sanctity or purity about
the motherland things like that
um so any culture war in america
you know like flag you know the american
flag though you know it's uh
if you're on the left well burning the
american flag is a kind of free speech
but if you're on the right the flag is
sacred it's not just a piece of cloth
so um so what i found from reading
ethnographies and looking at evolution
was
morality varies but the sort of the deep
psychological structures of it are
universal and once you understand that
now the way is open if you're a democrat
and you want to appeal
to to uh moderates and conservatives
don't frame it in terms of you know
oppression or suffering
frame it in terms of you know the the
you know the great american promise or
what's great about america or
um uh you know american traditions or
so you know something like that you can
you can you can couch almost any appeal
uh in you can ground it in foundations
that your listener
responds to i had this experience
countless times
on the trail i thought of you sometimes
uh john you should know
so i'll give you one example i
am for universal health care i think it
makes perfect sense it makes no sense
not to have
uh universal health care particularly in
this context it makes zero sense to tie
it to jobs
uh given that the majority of jobs now
are temporary gig or contract jobs and
you don't get benefits a lot of time
but when people ask me about universal
health care the way a lot of
folks frame it is in uh it's a human
right
and there is this caring
argument which i agree with 100 i mean
it's inhumane and
savage and barbaric that we have people
that don't have healthcare
but the way i would frame it often and i
totally believe this too so it wasn't
a stretch for me was look imagine
all of the americans who never started a
small business
never changed jobs never made some kind
of
independent venture happened because
they were stuck in a job that had health
care and they knew that they would lose
their health care if they lost it
that if you're pro entrepreneurship
pro-business creation
pro-risk-taking you should be for
universal healthcare too because this is
just awful for any form of economic
dynamism
uh and i completely like believe that i
mean it's true i've run a business and
like that they're you know
like this healthcare system does keep
people fixed in place in ways that's
that's not
um very positive um but that's an
argument that would work unlike a
different set of americans exactly then
that's right the caring and fairness
argument that's right because the right
so ronald reagan gave us the mod
well ronald reagan created the coalition
of
um of social conservatives um
uh and business conservatives or or
laissez faire
capitalists who are not conservative in
any way they're
the uh you know pro pro business but
they're not
social very different social
conservatives um and the third group is
authoritarians uh people who are prone
to
racism when triggered by the sense that
that our our moral order is coming apart
so the psychologically there's three
very different groups
social conservatives um uh libertarians
or laissez faire
conservatives or capitalists uh and
authoritarians
so he united those three into a very
powerful coalition
and the authoritarians uh were never in
the driver's seat they're less educated
they're more racist
uh they were never in the driver's seat
and that's what's unique about our era
is that the social the true social
conservatives who have a lot of respect
for
um a lot of them are anti-trump a lot of
them were you know are
sort of kicked out of the club uh so the
never trumpers a lot of those are
berkey and conservatives um and the
authoritarians for the first time
have at least the president's ear uh
they they are much more influential in
the modern right
coalition so it's kind of a mess now and
you know i have you know in the book you
can tell i think that i have a lot of
respect for conservatives and
libertarians
but as well as as well as the left but
um
but the but in the last four years the
republican party i think has kind of
lost its mind
because that reagan coalition is really
changing
and it's not conservative in any way
that i can recognize
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]
you